the russian economy is in free fall
economists to jpmorgan chase expect the
russian economy to contract a whopping 7
this year goldman sachs thinks the
damage could be worse predicting a 9
contraction in the russian economy
virtually every major corporation in the
world has stopped doing business in
russia
bp shell and exxon mobil have pulled out
of energy deals apple google and
facebook have blocked the kremlin from
their platforms
cnn has stopped broadcasting in russia
which shows that not everything is so
bad in that country every storm cloud
has a silver lining
but other than not having to stare at
brian stelter anymore things are going
about as poorly in russia as they
possibly could
by targeting russia's central bank with
sanctions an unprecedented tactic the
west has collapsed the russian ruble
nearly two-thirds of the 630 billion
dollars in the central bank's foreign
exchange reserves were frozen overnight
a financial expert summed up his take on
the situation by drinking live on
russian television to the death of their
stock market
worst case scenario he says i'm going to
go work at santa claus like i did 25
years ago
jokes aside let's do this quickly
send regards to sergey ushenko who drank
12 13 years ago to the death of the
stock market
today i'm drinking carbonated water dear
stock market you were close to us you
are interesting
rest in peace dear comrade
the host says i'm not going to comment
on this stunt because i don't want to
believe it
the west just wrecked russia
and with good reason
vladimir putin invaded a smaller weaker
neighboring country
whatever the nuances nothing comes
anywhere near justifying an all-out
russian invasion
nothing could justify the shelling of
civilian centers
and yet
putin's main domestic political rival
has complained that we in the west keep
falling into putin's traps
we might be doing it again
there are lots of people right now on
the left and the right clamoring to send
russia back to the stone age with
sanctions or missiles or both
the economic crisis we've inflicted is
already 40 to 80 percent worse than
russia's last worst economic catastrophe
in 1998.
some analysts predict it could
eventually be three times worse than the
collapse of 1998 when russia defaulted
on its debt
the economic catastrophe coincidentally
that launched putin to power in the
first place
the white house is confident that joe
biden's got everything under control
i was at the state department the
president was the vice president the
last time russia invaded ukraine this is
a pattern of horror from this president
from president putin and from the
cronies around him this is a pattern
this is a pattern of horror do you see
the pattern the pattern is that every
time biden goes up against putin putin
wins
the white house wants regime change in
russia
it worked out so well in iraq and egypt
and libya why not give it another go in
a nuclear former superpower without any
clear popular opposition leader what
could go wrong
but even if it's the right idea to take
putin out our leaders may very well have
just entrenched him or maybe someone
even worse in power
those who don't know history are doomed
to repeat it unfortunately our current
crop of rulers don't seem to know
anything at all
i'm glad you liked that clip now i need
you to subscribe ring that bell
hopefully get the notifications if
you're not getting notifications head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you